the fastest money that i got
was obviously the boxing like you know
six rounds
three minutes that's 18 minutes of
fighting and then i get paid
like a lot a lump sum so that's you know
that's probably the fastest amount that
i've made
was that was the lump sum for the boxing
like uh the percentage of the
pay-per-view revenue or was it like an
established upfront
lump sum with the first fight it was yes
but then with the second fight it wasn't
i had to deal with the zone
we went search away which the first
fight was the the first fight was uh
sorry the first fight was
uh whatever how much we make we split in
half and then we both get 50
uh 50 percent right and so that's of the
pay-per-view
yes of the pay-per-view and then the
second fight was just uh this is what
you get
i'm fine this is this is what you get
and then
you just fight which which one worked
out better for you
uh second one probably probably the
second one yeah
i guess and then he put it all on
bitcoin then he [ __ ] doubled it
did you did you bet on yourself boxing
or
or not uh with the first
ever fight i did yeah i bet about like
10k that's all i was allowed to
um do and uh yeah i would say i won
this was me versus joella right and that
was the
fight yeah that was an amateur fight
yeah but you were able to bet
so i was like this is pretty sick but uh
yeah with the second and third fight
against logan paul i did yeah
dude